pregunto por supuesto cómo llegamos a
este punto y qué podemos hacer para
nivelar esta balanza y además si es
imposible hacerlo en este punto
pues precisamente el nivel de consumo
que está llevando actualmente la
humanidad es el que nos ha llevado a
este punto de no retorno es una forma
simbólica de decirlo
hemos ya gastado los recursos naturales
suficientes que se pueden regenerar que
no lo hubiéramos gastado el 31 de
diciembre y actualmente estamos en un
déficit no es como gastar más de lo que
tienes en tu cuenta bancaria de lo que
tienes de los de tus ingresos entonces a
través de nuestro patrón de consumo en
nuestras emisiones de dióxido de carbono
de nuestra deforestación de toda la
producción masiva de carne animal es
como
el hemos creado un modelo en el cual
necesitamos 1.7 veces los recursos de la
tierra que no lo estamos gastando eso en
un año no están usando 74% veces más de
lo que se puede regenerar 'alejandro'
como consumir los recursos de esta
manera tan desmedida afecta a nuestro
futuro en la tierra no aprendimos nada
de la pandemia
no pues al parecer no hemos aprendido
nada si bien hubo una reducción y un
pequeño respiro para la tierra y del
consumo en cuanto a emisiones en el año
2020 se espera que ya haya un incremento
otra vez de nuevo mientras se vaya
saliendo la pandemia la con las
economías se vayan recuperando que se
vuelvan a incrementar los patrones de
consumo en los niveles de dióxido de
carbono hacia la atmósfera la
deforestación la sobreexplotación de los
recursos naturales y pues hasta la fecha
no vemos que los países tomen se tomen
en serio la crisis climática en la cual
estamos viviendo para poder revertir
esto que está sucediendo